so I prepared for a 10 minute 15-minute
presentation I just found out that we
may have a little more time than that
cause I'm concerned that that might be
good thing I think that might even be
good for you if I do my job right so
we'll see what I can do I imagine that
most people here heard of OpenCourseWare
anyone here not in the hope of course
would if I have to describe it just at a
really high level OpenCourseWare is an
open collection of university course
materials licensed in a way that they
can be freely access on the internet and
derivative works can be created there
from on to help in the university
experience so it's open educational
materials in a course structure
currently provided by universities
worldwide so that's an open courseware
is all about it's important to
understand that that it's not just
universities like MIT putting their
courses up but there are also
significant institutions that have
signed up to translate OpenCourseWare
courses in the multiple languages so we
have those in Spanish and Portuguese we
have those in Chinese and Japanese other
languages as well so it's not just the
content but the translations um I was
trying yesterday to think about how
OpenCourseWare fits with the rest of the
people in this room because the truth is
there's a lot of people doing archives
here there's a lot of people doing
digital libraries there's a lot of
content providers here how does that
really fit in with OpenCourseWare well
to be honest you may not need us but we
need you for sure what I mean by that is
today when a professor village of course
they build it on under fair use and so
they don't really have to think about
whether the stuff that they're using in
their course violates intellectual
property also you could argue that maybe
some of those courses aren't as exciting
as dynamic as they could be and so if
you think about the various archives the
various libraries the various digital
learning assets that many of you supply
if we can sort of bring those professors
along to become aware of what you're
providing then they could incorporate
your materials into their courses and
not only make their courses better have
the students learning experience is
better but also how do you feel like
your stuff is really making penetration
in important areas so I do think that
there's synergy there if we have a
particular niche in the oer space it's
that um we have a very targeted audience
you know we are structured courses in
the university setting where the
learning objects are in context and in
sequence because i'm sure many of you
have been the learning repositories i
won't give any names but you go there
and you do a search because you're
looking for stuff and yeah you can find
200,000 hits on a given search query but
is it usable is it good you know is it
in context how do you use it you know
sometimes that's challenging but when
its professors who are professionals
from credible institutions having
specific needs for enrolled learners
that provides a forcing function for
real value and for a target audience
with specific needs and so that's sort
of I'd say that might be some some of
the unique value proposition for what
open course was trying to do um you know
when I was a little kid I used to think
about how I know if I've made a
difference in the world and this isn't a
picture of me this is a picture of my
son Winston because he's cuter than I
was when I was a kid but as they think
about OpenCourseWare and I'm new and I'm
not send new to the game I've been doing
open court squirt for about two and a
half years but I i come from microsoft i
worked for seven years for microsoft
doing very fun and interesting things
but after about seven years and maybe 12
years in the computer industry I felt
this real compelling need to see if I
could throw my creative resources and
talents towards something that I would
feel might be a little bit more
meaningful and a little more significant
to the
so that's that's why i left microsoft
and and started getting a PhD in
instructional technology and trying to
figure out what my next step would be
and so i started doing open course for
about two and a half years ago but i
just joined MIT a few months back as an
employee so i worked for a mighty now
and and so as I think about
opencourseware in some ways it's not my
baby in some ways it's something that
other institutions have nurtured as I
was sort of in a marketing world but but
there are many things about
OpenCourseWare that really excite me um
if you give it a membership test you
know who's involved there's over 130
institutions worldwide involved in
europe in japan china cup leo few in
Africa several leading institutions in
the United States it's a growing
movement it's a movement with legs we
just met in San tender Spain to week two
or three weeks ago had over 120
attendees at the conference from 70 or
80 institutions it's it's no longer just
an MIT thing even though many people
associate MIT with OpenCourseWare that's
not a bad thing but MIT themselves would
say we don't want an open courseware to
be just an MIT thing here's a list of
all the consortium institutions it's
it's almost so sort of expensive that
you can't read it on a slide and this
leaves out probably at least ten to
twenty percent of other people who have
joined if you give it a quality test um
I'm impressed with me with the
institutions that are that are engaged
mit is certainly impressive Tufts and
Johns Hopkins Notre Dame top
universities in China Japan Spain France
New Zealand there are other schools of a
major note some of them here like
University of California Berkeley that
are in the process of joining up with
the consortium there are others as well
who are in the works but want to make
that official in our own way and so I
think that that we have a strong footing
in terms of quality
if you look at the Intercontinental test
everyone wants to do something
international right over 20 countries
are involved you know there's a map of
the number of schools and sort of where
they break out geographically it's clear
that we need to do some work in Central
and South America it's clear that we
need to do some work in Africa it's
clear that we need to think not just
supply side but also demand side and be
demand driven but we're clearly spanning
the globe dotting the globe with
OpenCourseWare we're now in over ten
languages there's opencourseware content
in over ten languages Chinese Japanese
Spanish Portuguese Thai Vietnamese etc
you know this is old but we're getting
over two and a half million visits per
month to the very simple course for
sites so some critical mass really is
starting to build and the blue
represents sexual original content in
the red represents the translation
affiliates if you look at the number of
courses we're now up to 5,000 plus this
again was the sly it has been updated
and it used to be that mi tease courses
dwarfed the number of courses outside of
MIT but now they're more course non MIT
opencourseware courses than MIT courses
which is also an important milestone if
you look at the PR test just over the
past few months we've been featured on
national public radio we've been
featured on marketplace we've had a Wall
Street Journal article we've been in the
christian science monitor on a lot of
international press I can't keep up with
all the with all the press people are
excited about what you're all here to do
open educational resources it's it's
it's very exciting and so we pass the PR
test and and there's even the man on the
street test and what that is is I like
to know that something that I'm doing
sort of reaches the average person that
I might meet I was at a party on Sunday
that's a picture of me in the top right
here in New York
city with some people I never met before
and this guy down here in the green
shirt his name's Daniel Bartholomew and
you know he stopped me and he said John
what do you do because we've never
talked about it I said all I did this
thing called up of course he goes you
opencourseware oh yeah it's kind of cool
he's why he goes no you do
OpenCourseWare you serious I heard about
that in MDR I was like good and he
wouldn't let it go you know he wants to
set up a meeting with me next week where
he could talk to me about it he's just
some guy doing computer stuff somewhere
so it's starting to penetrate people's
hearts and minds the vision of sharing
learning unlocking the knowledge so the
people who can't afford to enroll in a
university or who want to supplement
their University experience or a
professor that wants to improve their
course open and unlocking that learning
so that others can benefit from that's
what OpenCourseWare is about and what's
my mom says all my son's part of
OpenCourseWare you know I'll know little
I will done some people she's not there
yet I have to keep tell every six months
not what do you do again makes glad to
if you do the google test I was in Spain
does in Spain a couple weeks ago and i
went ahead and Google David Beckham to
see how many Google hits David Beckham
would return and he returned about three
million hits in google so I did the same
thing with OpenCourseWare is about 2.7
so basically we passed a David Beckham
death
you know which is an open courseware is
somewhat reached the status of David
Beckham that's not bad i mean i have
higher aspirations you know should it be
Britney Spears or what was sure to be
Jessica Simpson no um but but probably
the most important test of all
throughout the course where is the human
test you know are we are we really
helping people um this this fellas name
is wrong video what I was he's from
Venezuela and raheli Oh a fat man I
don't open courseware here and a half
ago a year and a half ago and he he's
studying scuba diving engineering so he
loved scuba-diving he loves underwater
welding and he loves engineering and he
was up on google one day trying to learn
more about his discipline so he Google's
his discipline and the any fines
OpenCourseWare he goes to it he finds a
couple courses from MIT that really
helped him in his job so he calls that
he sends an email to the people MIT
Steve Carson see Carson emailed him back
he's like I can't believe mi tease
actually having a conversation with me
I'm in Venezuela and he gets so excited
that he did he pays for his own flight
to fly to MIT just to learn more about
what up of course we're doing this isn't
a professor the others guys single he's
a bachelor he's just out of school but
he's just so excited about
OpenCourseWare that'll fly to MIT to
learn more we had this conference in
Spain as I mentioned a couple weeks ago
he put his plane ticket on his credit
card so that he could attend the open
courseware conference that's it that's
how much he believes in what's going on
so if if people are willing to make
sacrifices for something and they're
doing it from their heart to me that
says that we're doing something that's
significant that has traction it's maybe
a little more important than when the
David Beckham test this is a man named
Lucifer chew now I've never met someone
named Lucifer before have any of you
ever heard of Luke to anybody Luke to is
from Taiwan Luke to
is into fantasy literature and he had
the idea to translate the lord of the
rings trilogy into chinese so we went to
publishers in taiwan or wherever he went
and he said I'll make a deal with you
I'll I'll translate Lord of the Rings in
the Chinese and you know and i'll give
that to you don't have to pay me a penny
until we've sold over 100,000 copies but
once we sold over 100,000 copies you got
to take care of me and they pulled the
trigger they did the deal and he became
a millionaire after he became a
millionaire and he's an eccentric guy
after he became a millionaire Luke to it
around and he said what can I do to give
back he found out about what MIT was
doing with OpenCourseWare and he created
his own organization called oops and
what hoops does is it translates
OpenCourseWare courses into Chinese so
the Chinese people can benefit from he
has a volunteer force of a hundreds of
people he's bankrolling with his own
funds for the sea organization he has
hundreds of volunteers translating
hundreds of courses into Chinese because
that's what he believes is the best way
he can get back to the people little bit
so we did it and I'm not you know making
this up and so you know for me you know
that helps me feel like we're passing
the human touch maybe the most
inspirational story of all is my friend
month mood mock moon I met in Spain just
two weeks ago and I just happened to sit
next to him at a dinner and I was
talking to mock mood my moves from Iran
and he's of the bah' faith and many of
you know about the bah' faith in Iran
Iran isn't the best place to be bhai
necessarily on my food went to MIT back
in the 70s as
a suspected be a nuclear engineer and
then when the revolution happened in
Iran he had a chance to flee the country
because you know the revolution wasn't
one that sort of made the baha'i steel
like they they had a safe future and I
asked him why didn't you leave when he
had the chance and he said I'm not going
to abandon my people he said I can go
make some small difference somewhere
else in some part of the world be some
professor somewhere or go help on some
nuclear projects but where do I make the
biggest difference I can make the
biggest difference staying and helping
my bahay people that are in my
neighborhood the virginal city that are
in my region so he stayed and over time
it got to the point where people of the
bah' faith couldn't be accepted in the
University in Iran because as Jonah
mentioned to me yesterday they had were
announced I think they have to do some
kind of renounce their religion to them
to be able to attend the universities
and sign some type of I don't know the
details there but what I do know is that
Mahmoud and many of his professional
friends started a university for bahay
students that were disenfranchised and
these students have gone on to the top
universities in Europe but it has a
volunteer force of professors and when
these volunteer professors needed a
place to go to find curriculum to help
them build their courses guess where
they turned hope the course work so he's
willing to get a visa find himself out
of his own pocket to come to Spain to
learn more about how he can work with
other groups to learn how to do
OpenCourseWare to benefit not only
himself but for behind or around the
world so again I don't mean to be small
T but for me it's passing the human test
and this is something I just saw
yesterday forgive the small text this
time is also coming
but it was so moving to me that I had to
include the text and I didn't edit it
for some you know this is already online
courses of the greatest ever worldwide
educational rebel revelation ever
happened in the human history of
civilization this is a major keivom/new
dougie the Iranian seemed a fighter
pilot god no and last week I became
aware such great editor by MIT I could
not stop falling off my tears this is
what American are and the world must
learn not those civil wars I love to
present a gift to open courseware and I
wish to learn the correct mailing
address in the name of the person
responsible and receiving is proof thank
you very much for your great works I
know how hard it is and how much times
really have been invested in such huge
services to all human beings around the
world with no prejudice in an access to
education now i'm not here to sell you
the open courseware is going to save the
world right but it clearly is just
changing some parts of mind and it's not
a US based initiative though I think
that every nation has something to gain
by collaborating on something that
benefits all sort of the rising tide of
their cell ships so for me um
OpenCourseWare passes the human test at
least in its initial exceptions and I
was trying to think about how to just
cap because the Reston's presentation is
a little bit more maybe critical so the
best metaphor I could come for
OpenCourseWare is a picture of my
daughter Claire she's my third she's my
third child I don't love her any more
than the others um but I picked her
because of her age she's she's six years
old she learned to read when she was
four for some of you that wouldn't be
remarkable we were really excited about
that and when I think about Clara how do
I feel you know she makes me happy she
makes me smile I couldn't be prouder of
what she's accomplished I think she's an
amazing sort of spirit in the
swirls and that's how a lot of the
course work I love it it makes me smile
and I do think it's absolutely
incredible but when I think about my
daughter Clara you know is that it for
her is that sort of all she's ever going
to be or is there going to be more to
her story you know I think about what's
high school gonna be like what friends
has she given shoes where she's gonna go
to college and was she gonna get married
she can have a family she can be an
executive professor you know I have all
sorts of dreams and aspirations and just
like Clara opencourseware very young it
has so much to do but the potential is
really great and so um so instead of
calling this challenges or obstacles i
decided to call it opportunities for
growth but you can take that as a
euphemism where you could take it on
face value here's a quick sort of
discussion of the challenges from of
course where and where I want to eat
your where we will work together as we
try and help OpenCourseWare succeed here
are some of these four professors
openness and for universities it is just
a major paradigm shift I mean it's like
trying to convince someone that the Sun
is made of cheese is you want you to do
what you want to share you only to
boldly share my horses or university my
mind this is hollow you know my give you
away to learning no that's equals
visceral reaction the original reactions
I'll gap chair absolutely I would wear
eyes now it's like hey I got
uniform you know that's sometimes the
reaction okay especially when the money
comes from their own pockets it's one of
the great it's not other thing this is
something I have to do you know in
addition to their day charter so with
Creative Commons with you guys we have
to find a way to teach me to sort of
change the culture to where our people
thankful for people who go through
buildings from the beginning because
OpenCourseWare can't get afterthought
you can't like build your horse do 20
years and then come to the after that's
in them and they only have pull out
everything about intellectual property
replaced all the things you can go ahead
and find the job and insert without line
included in reserve eter to the GOP
horses new places and have two versions
of course how does one course but at the
four courses you teach I mean I all know
that that scale and so we have to be
happy to know about just like recycling
come about just like community to work
so they're sure a drug users of our
value open this has to become the
instinct than me this is where we need
to band together so that each of us in
our in commerce through the neighborhood
rewrite the laws of you you know we're
always running the Bulls are open
Oh Jo Jones a profit for me um you know
second issues we are open courseware is
managing growth I'm maintaining quality
there's lots of schools want to jump on
the open courseware vampire many of the
lobby associated MIT or you know they
want so to pay me back the our way but
if we just open it up to anybody you
want to be open but anybody says you
know you can have quality cabbages so
that's something that we are it's hard
to root for top university well top
international universities long
association and believing what we do but
you know University of right they want
to know ought to do their own thing
until we see for example an IT meeting
with something that they got a lot of
credit for today want to sort of be seen
as a follower you know that's sometimes
something that we would run up against
and in some ways I'm just guessing that
sometimes people think about that but it
makes sense to me on so we do have to
move it into something that everyone
feels like they can drive benefit from
and be a significant part of years old
of course we're too expensive I mean
think about the process it can cost up
to thirty thousand dollars per course
mass of course with the existing
materials an existing horse right cuz
imagine he says of youth out the stables
need a baby you guys so the CIA shows
you got your fireplace and also going to
take
time to go back in think about every
pitch every saddle club every little you
know formula to use what's his mind from
summer I sold them somewhere every day
I'm going to get out whatever place and
then he got a little doll back yet again
bring sign and then it put it out some
work where you put so it turns out that
is in some of your sense of the test in
fact so we don't let your property fair
use of rich content sallal an issue and
then um you know the brand is is
something that I think about a lot right
now when people think OpenCourseWare
they think course materials right when I
was miners out then I heard about open
courts won't like sweet i'm going to
learn something cool so i go to MIT site
and i type in some subjects i'm
interested in and then I see a syllabus
in some lecture notes where's the video
you know that's what I was and I didn't
understand what their vision was and
what their goal was but there are a lot
of people you know I say oh you've got a
cool online course general of course to
join up of course what they say to me
well I'm more focused on learning you
know you're kind of just putting course
materials out there my emphasis is
learning so I I'm not sure I want to be
associated opencourseware so do we keep
OpenCourseWare as it's currently
understood and trying to really do it
well or do we try and expand it and
maybe help bro people's understanding of
what it means it's a 30 question and
then how do we tap student excitement
students can become an incredibly
powerful resource if you think about the
civil rights movement the United States
right students were integral to that
being successful you can get students
excited about stuff
and leverage that asset of energy and a
talent but how do you do that so as they
think about why I'm here today one of
the questions I ask is is Richard
content like multimedia sort of the
secret sauce scope of course we're
really taking off or is it some bird you
can argue though of course where's
expensive enough as it is trying as
anxious to do it in rich multimedia
format I mean you're just sort of
throwing extra bricks on the backpack
you know so that's that's sort of what
I'd love to brainstorm with you of guys
with you guys about so about the video
just quickly what we're doing I asked
all the open course refers to tell me
what they've been doing with video mit
has about twenty one out of 1,650
courses haven't what's of course Canada
1674 mi tease got about twenty one
courses with full lecture videos 30 with
exemplary lectures 20 with faculty
introduction videos 50 with special
video for about 700 total hours of video
out of about yet so around 1650 so
that's exciting I mean a lot of people
have no idea that actually MIT
OpenCourseWare runs again from super
rich courses to sort of the bear models
but that does represent a small subset
of their total of course catalog and
that's by design for them so it's not
it's just where they are open university
in the UK is another major
OpenCourseWare partner they have you
know these these types of numbers and
that that's a type they don't have 1650
courses open university k now when I was
a grad student a state university I was
aspiring moreover course we're so in a
graduate in a graduate level as I have
instructional technology I said I'm
going to create a multimedia experience
in open court square as a grad student
and I had a couple of we did a project
as a group for a class assignment we
just decided we were going to record the
professor's the lectures of a professor
this professor has doctor recently crapo
he wrote the book on a cultural
anthropology of religion major publisher
he's one of the world leaders in
anthropology religion you wouldn't think
that at a university maybe like Intel
State you might think agriculture or you
may not think you tested at all um but
that's what that's what he does and so
um so what I did is I just I went to dr.
crapo and I said we want to film we want
to film you um we want you know you're
you're you're coming close to graduation
you've spent your life you've spent your
life building these sets of lectures and
when you retire your life's work is
going to retire with you who's going to
know who's going to know the great
stories you can tell who's going to know
the great concepts that you can convey
it skin it's going to get shelved
yeah let's let's get to that I'll be
I'll be very quick so so here we are in
anthropology now and so what I did is
like kind of deal with them i said look
give me 10 hours of your time over two
months I'll show up I got this little
prosumer little camera I'll show up in
your conference room and I'll just spend
an hour and you just do do your thing do
you think it's not in class there's a
lot of pressure it's very little
production um but basically I just have
him sit down and I said do your thing
and so I filmed him and then as a grad
student I used the rest of the semester
to edit down the video I did it all
myself using a Mac and I broke it out of
the little five minute chunks so that
the metadata could be could be leveraged
and it could be searched upon by topic
you know and this was the experience
that I was able to come up with its not
earth-shattering it's not a you know ken
burns there's no Ken Burns effect here I
don't even know if they have audio on
this is awesome really resolution and to
be honest I think I think this is a
better experience than what the students
get in the classroom because it was like
a conversation you know I'm like Hawking
home asking you follow up he sees my
facial expressions and he's not like
thinking has to be a didactic right did
you have a comic good for you what do
you mean you as you being there oh yeah
yeah okay yeah so anyway so that's what
I did and I you know I'm proud of that
little thing and it cost I I sort of
figured out what my time would have been
and you know was a few thousand dollars
is what it would have cost it if you had
to pay for it but are there graduate
students or undergraduate students who
could maybe get a three hours worth of
credit to produce a course and work more
directly with the professor and then you
would have to pan so I'm thinking how do
we make OpenCourseWare more affordable
and richer at the same time and maybe
have students benefit and professors so
those are some of the things that I was
thinking about and and so that's one
small example of some of the
brainstorming we might do on together
and where we might need some of your
help so so just to summarize what do we
need we need openness as an instinctive
value we need to bring on more quality
institutions worst case western are they
still here I mean what you guys are
doing seems so there's so much we could
learn from you and maybe we could help
you
you know help you promote what you're
doing bring your University more
recognition I mean because I you
probably knows better i was a lot of
people have no idea case question is or
what they do or where they are I mean
from Texas and I've never heard of them
so you know maybe we could drive your
institution more awareness through a
link on our OpenCourseWare portal maybe
the departments were you're really a
specialty we could build awareness so
that they could sort of move up in the
rankings maybe the professors who are
trying to get tenure could all sudden
get a quote in the wall street journal
called The Christian Science Monitor
that sort of allows them to get more
visibility and over time you know we
could provide you enough of a benefit to
where you would want to join in and and
we might be able to you know you might
be able to help us as well so how do we
keep breeding on quality institutions
how do we refine the value proposition
by lowering the cost instill in
increasing the pact of the core impact
of the course content um and so for me
this man on the street test is sort of
inadequate instead of saying dude
OpenCourseWare it's amazing idea that
the way the I think of OpenCourseWare
becoming sustainable is if people start
saying things like you know and this is
gonna sound melodramatic but dude I got
off welfare in part because of OPA
coursework right because he was able to
take learn apply it helped him get a
better job that would be something that
would start to sort of command people's
commitment for resources or you know
dude I got an A or even a PhD as a
university student because I was able to
use your course to help me in my
learning experience or let's say it's a
professor which probably otakon say dude
but he may say John you know I got
tenure in part because of OpenCourseWare
or mr. Glenn my department moved up in
the US News and World Report rankings in
part because of OpenCourseWare so just
the old final question I had is is
multimedia an important ingredient felt
the course where teachers and says maybe
so maybe not and if so who in this room
can we partner with tell make that
successful
maybe we can drive your content further
maybe your university can give me home
become a part of it maybe not so that we
go from how will they know if I made a
difference to the wise old man saying
wow you know I was a part of that whole
oer those need anything all right well
we're past time so thank you